[Music]
before we went to break
uh we were talking with sean and uh sean
had called in
and let us know that he had co-signed
for his daughter
on a vehicle his daughter had some some
health issues
uh and he was now responsible in dealing
with this the bank repossessed the
vehicle
uh sold it and now they're trying to
come after you
for the 11 500 difference
but sean you mentioned that they offered
you some type of settlement for around
six thousand
is that correct well a sixty percent
settlement okay which comes out to just
over seven thousand dollars
okay just over seven thousand so uh
what i did i called him this morning
just to see if
if i could negotiate that and i just
said i just
i asked you know could could we offer
you a thousand dollars and
and the people said no we don't
negotiate
so my question for you guys is am i
better off
making minimum payments am i better off
because if i make minimum payments
they're going to hold the debt clear up
until the full 11
500 is paid off or do i
not do anything and let it go to uh
collections
and then deal with the collection agent
okay so let me ask you this
what i've heard is that they will deal
with sean what is your household income
uh about seventy thousand dollars okay
all right
and so you guys you said what other
debts do you have
uh our mortgage okay and so you
qualified for this so
you you told them you should be able to
pay this
well and yeah i'm i'm a teacher and we
get uh we've also got 11
kids okay so there's a you have 11 kids
there are other medical bills in the
that we're making payments on
okay that are and
for that matter this daughter's medical
bill she's been in the hospital
quite a bit the past couple of months
and so
we don't know what all those are going
to be yet i understand how many of the
11 kids are living with you all
right now there's uh three of them three
of them okay
they're all adults but they're they're
still living at home okay
yeah uh i want to hear your thoughts
here's the deal
you know number one this is a lesson
john about cosigning
because when you co-sign what you're
saying is you're guaranteeing
that the loan is going to be paid your
daughter did not qualify for this loan
on her own the only way she got it was
because
you were on this loan uh so first and
foremost you're going to need to go in
and talk to the bank
uh and communicate with them uh in in
talking about what they're willing to do
if they will put that seven thousand
dollar i mean number one let's face it
it would have been better off for you
all to sell this vehicle yourself as
opposed to letting it get repossessed
because you could have sold it for a lot
more right they gave it away for about 8
500 now they're coming after you
i would go in i would detail your
situation to the bank
about the other medical situations and
all that's going on in the health
issues with your daughter get them to
put that dollar amount in writing
and you got to start making payments on
this thing uh you know for you to say
well i'll just wait
and let it go to collections well now
you've got the potential of adding some
other legal issues on top of it well
technically right now hogan he's already
in collections and this is what i
recommend especially me
my very first job was in the collection
field and i did that for three years
uh right now the senate that they will
not negotiate here's what i want you to
do sean
don't make any payments yet i want you
to get up at least three to four
thousand dollars
uh most collection agencies buy this on
cents on a dollar
the best time to negotiate with
collection agencies is the last week of
the month
and you go then go to them and say you
know what i'll give you 35 cents on a
dollar that's about 3 300
at 11 000 and you wait to the last three
business days
they will budge they will bite at the
end of the day
you signed you you told them hey i will
help pay this if my daughter cannot
so legally you have to do it and morally
you have to do it
this is not a convenient way you can't
push it all on your daughter and i'm
sorry that you made this decision
uh but how you get out of this right now
is get up a bunch
get get at least three to four thousand
dollars and tell them hey this is the
best thing i can do
as a co-signer offered offer that to
them the very last week
of this um uh the last week of this
month and i guarantee you they'll help
them out
yeah i i too have been in collections uh
and and have done that
the the reality is is right now it
sounds like to me it's still with the
original bank
so it hasn't gone to a collection status
yet
and as far as you're behind but they
haven't sold it off
i still think and again you're right and
as far as coming to settle that
thing they're going to take money
because they're greedy right so having
some money
uh getting it saved up is going to be a
big thing but i think you if you can't
pay
you can at least pay attention and what
i mean by that is having communication
with them to help them to understand
that hey here's the deal i've got health
issues and i'm going to take care of my
kids health
long before i worry about this thing and
so here the reality of you know as you
as you start to weigh um this doesn't
even become a factor when you're trying
to keep your kids
healthy and doing well but communicate
talk with them lay it out and i'm with
anthony you get up some dollar amount
and go in
as long as you don't pay them until they
tell you they're willing to accept this
payment as payment in full
yes right which means they're not coming
back to see you they're gonna write you
a letter that says that
and then you can hand over the three to
four grand or whatever it is
if people won't put the settlement offer
in writing i'm telling you it's not
real yeah all right so the moral of this
don't cosign yeah okay don't cosign i
people will try to guilt you they will
try to family members will try to make
you feel bad
uh listen i won't cosign for myself just
process it okay
bottom line is you're guaranteeing it
and what you end up doing a lot of
people
they don't think that hey if they can't
pay then i'm going to have to
yeah and that's exactly what happens and
anthony what gets me more riled up
than situations like this is to think of
the grandparents out there
that end up co-signing for junior or
juniet
and and they don't make a payment and
now they have to deal with their social
security
or whatever and they're stuck with the
payment you know hogan i had that come
up
about a few months ago a grandmother
makes maybe about 900
from a social security check but she has
a 800 credit score co-signed on her
uh grandson's bmw
1200 payment brand new and uh
he couldn't make the payments and they
called her and the bank realized that
there's no way in the world that she can
do it
no no so it's it's just um
it's predatory lending yes because
there's no way on an earth her making
900 a month she should have been a
co-signer on a 1200
payment but you know what they did you
know what the banks are doing i mean not
the banks you know the car dealership is
doing
lying on her income because her credit
score was so strong
they don't have to prove her income oh
so it was like these dealerships men are
just
just misusing people and just
anyways that's why we just teach don't
do debt yeah and here's the deal let me
let's talk about this if you're running
behind on your payments typically by the
time you get three to four payments
behind
they pr they are talking repossession
i want you to contact them i want you to
outright try to sell the car
the vehicle you're going to do a better
job of selling it you're going to get
more money than they are
because once the bank or the car
dealership repossesses it
they're going to take it to an auction
the auction is going to sell it to the
highest bidder
and then the bank is going to turn
around to come to you for the difference
and this is what sean
is dealing with so again if you can't
pay pay
attention to it uh try to work it out
you're going to
advocate for you much better uh than
than than the bank will
and so you have to have that mindset uh
this is stressful
and we've got people right now uh in a
position
uh throughout this covet situation
anthony that are having to make some
choices about what they can afford to
pay
yeah you know and here's the thing we
already know what you need to be paying
right now you need to be focused on the
four walls okay tell them all right
america listen to me clearly you're
gonna focus on your house
you're gonna focus on your
transportation and your transportation
is make sure you got gas and
cars running make sure you got food make
sure you got your lights on your
utilities
so those are the four main things that
you need to be focusing on right now and
then
if you have those four walls covered
during this season
then let's start looking at paying uh
your bills but right now
make sure that you and your family are
safe but let's say for example you do
have your job you do have the income
coming in
and let's say you do have some student
loans that's your only debt out there
right now
what student loans have been pushed off
to december go ahead and pay those
okay so have your priorities follow the
process
follow the system and i promise you you
will be okay and we're right here we're
going to walk you through this process